introducing the new Lego Sonic
collaboration featuring the iconic blue
Hedgehog Sonic hey make sure to mention
how amazing my sets are please don't
interrupt me my bad see you Sonic DJs
yes and eat chili dogs yep and uses the
speeds for you to go really fast hi what
I think you need to emphasize how fast I
am I said you went really fast yeah but
I go really really fast you want me to
say really really fast actually say
really really really fast
see is the speed sphere goes really
really really could you add awesome
before speed sphere any other request
nah you're doing great
C is the awesome speed sphere goes
really really really fast
[Music]
[Applause]
Sonic's fast friend tales in his
workshop with his iconic Tornado plane
time to do the barrel roll Tails
now let's head to Amy Rose's animal
rescue Island Amy with her trusty Hammer
hey Sonic yes Mr Sky voice if you're
really so fast try and beat me to the
Green Hill Zone Loop challenge
yes gotcha Sonic who's fast now now we
can take our time admiring this nice
loop-de-loop a nice ring beat turn
around
how did you get in here I told you I'm
really really really fast
and I am really really
real snub from the product reveal ad am
I rodent you'll regret this too Lego
company oh boy here we go